-Today is Friday,
and that's usually when I
catch up
with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some emails
and of course send out
thank you notes.
And I was...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...running a bit behind today.
So, I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind, I would like
to write out my weekly
thank you notes right now.
Is that okay with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
James -- James, can I get some
thank you note
writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
He was almost smiling
for a second.
-A little bit.
-Almost.
-And that's it.
Wow.
-Thank you, "Euphoria,"
for being the first show
whose parental warning is,
maybe just don't
watch this with
your parents.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Your show.
That's your show.
-Have you seen it?
-What's that?
-You watch "Euphoria"?
-Yeah, of course.
-It's a good show.
-It's fantastic, yeah.
-It's for the kids, right?
-I watch with my parents.
-Do you really?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I don't watch anything
with my parents.
-No, it's embarrassing.
-Anything risque or anything.
-Yeah, no.
-I'd be embarrassed.
-I don't even like watching
risque stuff with myself.
[ Laughter ]
I, like, close my own eyes,
go "Don't look." You know?
-You close your eyes
and you blind fold yourself?
-Yeah, blindfold myself.
"Don't look."
This is risque.
-Well, it looks like you
left yourself a little crack --
-Well, I let myself see
so I know what not to watch.
-Oh, yeah, yes.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, the D.C. Trucker
convoy protesting vaccines
for answering the question,
what would happen
if Optimus Prime got really
into QAnon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, February weather,
for giving me 28 chances
to wear the wrong thing
every day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Are you kidding me?
70 degrees?
-I'm leaving my coat at home.
-No, it's 30 degrees.
-30?
-Yeah.
Thank you, "Love Is Blind"
for reminding us that two people
can fall in love as long
as they drink enough wine
and never have to be in
the same room as each other.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Thank you, Kraft,
for calling new plant-based
hot dogs "Not Hot Dogs."
[ Laughter ]
Or as 7-Eleven, hot dogs put it,
"Hey, that's our thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a hot dog or a taquito.
Just take a bite.
You'll find out what it is.
Oh, it's a taquito.
-Oh.
I thought it was a hot dog.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, the original
"Law & Order" for coming back
to TV after 12 long years.
I really thought
that you were done-done.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you, buying corn tortillas
at the grocery store.
I only need three or four, but
sure, I guess I'll take 600.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You want 600 tortillas?
-They're all stuck together.
They're one tortilla.
[ Imitating tortilla ripping ]
-Thank you, wind, for just being
air that's in a hurry.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I got to -- I got to go.
I got things to do,
I got things to do.
Thank you, wine bottle opener,
for always looking like
you desperately need
to shave your armpits.
There you have it,
right there, folks.
Those are my thank you notes.